actress Anne Hathaway has been a very
vocal fan of RuPaul's Drag Race
the last few years when we caught up
with her for ocean's 8 she said she had
never met RuPaul before and if she had
her way she'd want Roux in the next
oceans film you had a great one the
other two have hot what was my really
really RuPaul's Drag Races hi it's my
show yeah that's amazing
have you guys met before Wow I'm
obsessed with all of them last night
while appearing on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert and explained that
RuPaul's Drag Race is comforting for her
but she had still not met the iconic
star you know what there is a show that
I do watch to make me yeah
drag race yes have you met RuPaul no
I've never met well he's my guest
tomorrow night would you like me to send
a message to him is there anything you'd
like to say to him I couldn't talk like
yeah just say I love you well surprise
thanks to Steven and finally had her
chance to meet RuPaul
is there anything you'd like to say to
roll darling you are the winner of this
week's challenge
Shante you stay
and while talking about one of the
all-stars for winners
Monet exchange and got emotional about
her journey on the show
Monet exchanges entire exchange it's
higher journey and just how amazing she
was in season 10 now that's a true fan
I'm really take this very serious and
then the growth between season 10 and
season 11 of the way she's okay so
Anne's dream came true now it's time for
mine and you are invited to my house any
time to watch drag race but be prepared
because things get a little heated I
wouldn't miss it for my mother today
Andrew we need to get in on season 12 as
a guest judge that would be epic
so what do you think of Anne's drag race
obsession which celebrity would you want
to watch drag race with who are you
rooting for this season let me know in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
it's my show I'm obsessed with all of
them
[Music]